[Musique]
bonsoir
j'imagine que vous occuper un emploi ou
que vous étudiez probablement pour un
jour occuper un emploi
est ce le cas oui et bien est-ce que
vous êtes septiers un jour d'occuper un
emploi sans être énumérées non non si
oui
accepteriez-vous d'avoir un patron de
porter un uniforme de travail d'avoir
des collègues qui eux sont salariés mais
pas vous est-ce que vous accepteriez ça
non est-ce que vous accepteriez grâce à
vos efforts vous permettez à d'autres de
tirer des profits
vous l'avez répondu j'imagine est aussi
que la plupart d'entre vous répondrais
non à cette question mais les personnes
en situation d'handicap sont présents
dans les milieux de travail
malheureusement elles ne sont pas
toujours payés à leur juste valeur les
conditions que j'ai que je vous ai
mentionné en introduction sont souvent
celles des personnes qui ont une
limitation intellectuelle
le travail salle occupe une place très
significatif dans la vie des personnes
qui ont une limitation intellectuelle ou
non cependant au canada le taux d'emploi
de ces personnes est d'environ du tiers
inférieur à celui de l'ensemble de la
population au canada pourquoi parce que
majoritairement à cause d'une tendance à
chercher les candidats idéaux
cela fait en sorte que nous pouvons pas
miser sur l'ensemble des talents de
l'ensemble des employés et ça crie
réellement un obstacle à la création de
milieux de travail réellement inclusif
donc aujourd'hui dans ma présentation je
vais vous parler de deux aspects donc
d'abord je vais vous parler en fait deux
modèles d'accompagnement en milieu de
travail par l'édification
de ces entreprises qui veulent embaucher
de façon plus inclusive et ensuite je
vous exposerai quatre caractéristiques
essentielles quatre caractéristiques
essentielles qui sont communes chez les
leaders d'entreprises qui veulent ou
s'ils bâtir des milieux davantage
inclusif
au terme de cette présentation j'espère
que je vous aurais convaincu des
bénéfices de l'embauché inclusif
j'ai consacré plusieurs années de ma
carrière à intervenir auprès des
employeurs afin que les populations plus
marginalisés ou les populations plus
vulnérables et un meilleur accès au
milieu de travail dans les quatre
dernières années
je suis intervenu davantage auprès des
employeurs afin de lutter contre les
préjugés des personnes qui ont une
déficience intellectuelle ou un trouble
du spectre de l'autisme un tsa
en fait mes collègues et moi nous sommes
intervenus au niveau des entreprises
afin que les personnes qui ont une
déficience intellectuelle ou un trouble
du spectre de l'autisme puisse être
connue sur le milieu de travail afin que
ces personnes puissent faire valoir
leurs réelles compétences comment au
niveau d'une sensibilisation qui va au
delà de cette étape afin que ces
personnes là est des vrais seins vrai
salaire de vrais emplois comme tout le
monde dans l'entreprise je suis
intervenu auprès d'un bon nombre
d'employeurs un bon nombre d'employeurs
m'ont dit il faut que je paye pour ce
monde là qu bien vous me payez pour que
vous pourrez intégrer ces personnes là
dans mon entreprise
ben ce monde là les personnes qui ont
une déficience intellectuelle ou un
trouble du spectre de l'autisme
moi je leur répondais que seydou sy bon
candidat que les autres employés dans
l'entreprise
il s'agit de faire quelques
accommodements et que je peux les mettre
en relation avec tout un bassin de
candidats très talentueux
les différentes actions du programme
très disponible et capable ont permis
d'intervenir auprès des employeurs de la
détermination des besoins en termes de
recrutement si vous mettez un emploi de
ces personnes pour que d'une part les
employeurs trouvent des candidats de
talent mais que les personnes aussi
puissent s'épanouir dans ces emplois là
de vrais emplois sur les 10 aux mêmes
conditions que les autres emplois
et dans l'entreprise heureusement encore
aujourd'hui un bon nombre d'entreprises
dans le monde accorde une réelle
importance à la diversité et à
l'inclusion la diversité engendre la
créativité plus d'entreprises misent sur
les compétences des personnes en
situation d'handicap plus celle ci est
capable de s'adapter aux aléas d'innover
et de prospérer selon plusieurs
recherches selon des indicateurs les
entreprises qui son père forain qui sont
plus diversifiées of un meilleur
rendement
comparativement à des milieux qui sont
non adaptatif ensuite les
caractéristiques essentielles sont
communes aux leaders d'entreprise
j'ai constaté dans mon parcours qu'il y
a quatre caractéristiques essentielles
qui sont comme le nos leaders
d'entreprises tabarre la créativité la
flexibilité la communication et la
collaboration
contrairement aux croyances populaires
les accommodements ne sont pas quelque
chose de très coûteux en entreprise ça
révéler davantage de la volonté des
leaders d'entreprise de leur créativité
et de leur flexibilité
l'inclusion ça se définit dans ce procès
cela d'une part entre une entreprise qui
est capable de s'ajuster
une entreprise qui est aussi capable de
se réajuster afin que les personnes en
situation d'handicap puissent avoir
accès aux mêmes conditions que tout le
monde dans l'entreprise la commune man
est un moyen pour mettre fin à une
situation de discrimination et les un
des fondements de la charte des droits
et libertés de la personne au québec
afin que toute personne puisse
bénéficier des mêmes conditions qu'à
l'ensemble de la population donc des
exemples dako bonnement par exemple un
accompagnement pour une personne en
situation de handicap pourrait être
d'exiger que cette personne soit jumelé
à un moteur dans l'entreprise ça
pourrait aussi être
de mettre en place un processus
d'apprentissage graduelle des tâches ou
des activités que l'employé aura
accroché tout au long de la journée
ensuite en terme de créativité de
flexibilité b voir au-delà des
apparences ça représente un réel défi
pour les entreprises
est-ce que c'est essentiel par exemple
d'exiger un secondaire 5 ou 12 années
d'études il faut se poser la question
sur chaque élément et les marques sont
mis de l'avant par les gestionnaires
afin que ce site devienne pas
discriminant le troisième la troisième
caractéristique essentielle c'est la
communication
donc la communication permet de passer
de la parole aux actes
la communication aussi c'est ce qui
permet de mettre les accommodements en
place dès le début du processus de
sélection du début du processus de
recrutement
l'employeur doit aussi respecter la
confidentialité doit respecter la vie
privée de la personne mais doit aussi
s'assurer de rencontrer ses obligations
légales donc une bonne pratique par
exemple pour être une gestionnaire qui
qui demande lors de l'appel pour une
entrevue d'embauché si l'employé aurait
peu des besoins particuliers ici pour
cette personne là ça serait pas possible
de mettre quelques accommodements en
place a fait que cette personne ne
puisse démontrer ses habiletés comme
toutes les autres personnes dans
l'entreprise donc c'est un exemple de
communication
d'un autre côté une bonne communication
d'entreprise qui permet aussi d'innover
grâce à l'embauché inclusive pourrait
être un autre exemple une gestionnaire
qui annonça son équipe l'arrivée d'une
personne qui ont une déficience
intellectuelle
donc c'est arrivé dans le cadre de la
collaboration puis il ya une des
collègues de travail qui a elle même
pris l'initiative d'améliorer et tout un
système de classement dossier puisque
cette personne aura effectué un
traitement des dossiers donc ça l'est
vraiment améliorer le milieu de travail
ça lui permet d'une part au milieu de
travail d'être plus productifs tout en
permettant un meilleur une main
intégration pour le futur employé donc
ça revitalise vraiment les milieux de
travail et s'alimente par ce fait même
la productivité des entreprises
finalement en termes de dernière
caractéristique c'est la collaboration
la collaboration ça permet aux
entreprises qui veulent embaucher de
façon inclusive de ne pas travailler
ainsi un silo la collaboration s'est
aussi d'inciter les collègues de travail
les employés les ressources humaines les
dirigeants de l'entreprise afin de
permettre un meilleur accès à ces
entreprises là à tous les candidats et
les candidates la collaboration ça peut
aussi être de collaborer avec les
organismes en employabilité
vous savez les personnes qui ont un
trouble du spectre de l'autisme ou une
déficience intellectuelle
c'est des personnes qui ont besoin de
soutien dans leur vie quotidienne
pour la majorité d'entre elles elles
pourraient ou savoir un besoin pour se
faire conseiller ou pour ce faire se
faire accompagner dans leur recherche
d'emploi
donc les gestionnaires qui décide
d'embaucher de façon inclusive doivent
absolument tisser des liens avec le
milieu communautaire c'est essentiel
cette collaboration un des employeurs
nous a mentionné dernier dernièrement
que l'arrivée de l'employé ou c'est son
entreprise mais ça le permis d'une part
de revoir les processus d'embauché mais
c'est le permis aussi de constater que
cette personne là c'est vraiment un
employé clé dans l'est dans l'entreprise
ça permet à tout le monde est davantage
ouverts dans l'entreprise ça permet
d'améliorer les processus les processus
d'être très attentif mais ce qu'il me
dit c'est quelque chose de très
important c'est que ça lui a permis
permis de constater que ce qu'il a fait
pour cette personne là ça devrait être
mis en place pour tout le monde dans
l'entreprise afin de crier ce milieu de
travail vraiment très inclusif donc pour
les entreprises
innover et prospérer c'est vraiment
possible grâce à l' embauche inclusive
pour les entreprises que la vente qui
ont cette volonté là
de collaborer avec le milieu c'est
quelque chose qui à la fois facilitant
facile rappelons nous il y a quatre
caractéristiques essentielles
je suis persuadé que vous les avez cette
caractéristique là la communication la
flexibilité la collaboration et la
créativité
aujourd'hui il ya tout un noyau de
gestionnaires qui ont décidé d'embaucher
de façon inclusive c'est un exemple pour
plusieurs autres entreprises
petit à petit elle est celle du canada
il s'agit d'une réelle volonté des
personnes qui elles mêmes veulent
travailler
donc si un dispositif s'est mis en place
grâce à un travail de collaboration
aussi d'expérience de partage de
ressources 95 % des employeurs qui ont
décidé d'embaucher avec le programme
très disponible et capables nous ont
même dit que les personnes qui ont une
déficience intellectuelle ou un trouble
du spectre les dix sont d'aussi bons
employés que les autres ou même meilleur
et je vous rappelle
c'est pas pour n'importe quel emploi
c'est le même que le vote de vrais
emplois aux mêmes conditions que tous
les autres employés de l'entreprise
j'aimerais remercier le programme très
disponible et capables qui est une
initiative de l'association canadienne
pour l'intégration communautaire et
l'alliance canadienne des troubles du
spectre de l'autisme
j'aimerais remercier la société
québécoise de la déficience
intellectuelle
la fondation miriam les employeurs les
organistes employabilité qui ont permis
récemment plus de deux mille embauches à
travers le pays ce qui est très
favorable
et rappelons-nous nous pouvons tous
contribuer à la création de saison
bossler inclusive par l'édification
d'une société plus juste et plus
équitable
merci à vous pour votre écoute
[Applaudissements]